avec nous à vif arif il est avocat et
spécialiste des droits de l'homme
merci monsieur arrive d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france première
question réaction après cette attente
avoir trié pardon j'ai pas entendu la
question je suis vraiment désolé une
première réaction peut-être après cet
attentat
évidemment c'est une réaction qui est
une réaction des froids c'est une
réaction qui est la consternation de ce
qui a pu se passer une condamnation
ferme et sans appel de ce qui vient de
se passer et puis moi je rejoins je
pense que c'est assez connu moi je suis
musulman de la communauté musulmane à
mahdia et le représentant de cette
mouvance religieuse a condamné très
fermement et sans appel ce qui vient de
se passer dans cette église est donc je
rejoins tout à fait à cette condamnation
claire et définitive
alors vous l'avez twitté un tout à
l'heure à nice et la ville qui connaît
le plus de caméras de vidéosurveillance
a d'ailleurs est un des arguments
électorale d'estrosi que s'est il passé
comment et pourquoi en sommes-nous
arrivés là en tout cas c'est une
question que vous est posée pourquoi
parler de la vidéosurveillance à nice ce
long voile et inefficace selon moi
écouter tout à l'heure on entendait
monsieur collard qui disait justement
que il fallait avancer vers une des
modèles que l'on connaît déjà dans la
lutte antiterroriste des modèles
exemplaires notamment israël l'israël
isation de la france et notamment sur le
plan de la lutte antiterroriste a été
proposé par un bon nombre de personnes
et ce qui est compréhensible parce que
israël fait face à un certain nombre de
menaces et donc a pu développer une
politique au regard de toutes ces
menaces là maintenant la question qu'il
faudrait se poser c'est aujourd'hui en
premier lieu nice un certain nombre de
caméras de vidéosurveillance et je crois
qu'il ya eu des reportages qui ont été
faits sur le sujet et c'est la ville qui
compte le plus de nuée de caméras bon je
peux peut-être me tromper a une ou deux
villes pré mais en tout cas c'est une
ville qui compte un certain nombre de
caméras de vidéosurveillance
ces caméras de vidéosurveillance elles
ont été mises en place notamment après 2
15 et après l'attentât de nice pour
justement prévoir et éventuellement
prévenir des attentats terroristes et ça
a sûrement été le cas puisque les
services de renseignement et on le sait
très bien malheureusement non pas la
publicité des l'ensemble des attaques
ils ont déjoué et on fait
malheureusement des éditions c'est vrai
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus étendue pour
les attaques qui sont perpétuées et
qu'ils sont réalisés par les terroristes
maintenant les services de renseignement
et je revins monsieur collard sur ce
point là c'est que ils font un travail
exceptionnel mais je pense qu'ils n'ont
pas de moyens et je crois que
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la
vidéo-surveillance qui va nous permettre
de déjouer des attentats
certes elle va jouer un rôle majeur et
elle va jouer un rôle important dans la
lutte antiterroriste mais c'est surtout
le renseignement humain qui va jouer et
là dessus il faut impérativement que
l'état se rendent compte que il y a de
moins en moins d'intelligence humaine
qui est fait sur le terrain il y a de
moins en moins de personnes qui vont sur
le terrain notamment en syrie pour
comprendre la logistique etc
et ça ça joue contre nous ça joue contre
nous parce que finalement ces
renseignements de terrain et beaucoup de
rapports sur l'intelligence le disent
sont les renseignements parfois les plus
efficaces pour déjouer des attaques
terroristes
alors maintenant il ya un autre
phénomène aussi c'est que ces attaques
sont souvent assez imprévisible on les
comprend pas trop elle arrive
soudainement et ce fut le cas avec
samuel pâtit
on ne sait pas encore exactement les
contextes précis de la sphère dans à
nice mais et on va le savoir mais en
tout cas il y a effectivement une
question qu'il faut se poser c'est est
ce qu'on ne met pas trop de moyens dans
la vidéosurveillance est ce qu'il
faudrait pas mettre un peu plus de
moyens dans le renseignement est bas
alors monsieur arif
en effet on a pas plus d'éléments sur
l'attentât adonis en tout cas une
information qui vient de
tombé selon une source proche du dossier
l'assaillant serait un tunisien de 21
ans il est arrivé par l'île de lampedusa
monsieur arif bien évidemment à tort ou
à raison d'identité de la feuille en va
bien remettre au coeur des débats la
lutte contre l'immigration
écoutez oui bah de toute façon ça avait
déjà été le cas avec sa mère pattie je
veux dire on a fait on a on a beaucoup
parlé limité de la lutte contre
l'immigration on a parlé d'avoir ordonné
mettre en pause notre droit d'asile
enfin il ya eu des déclarations qui ont
été complètement ubuesque je veux dire
il y a deux choses il y a le fait qu' il
faut évidemment regarder qui entre dans
notre pays ça c'est une chose importante
et il faut le regarder
très clairement et il faut avoir une
analyse des dossiers qui sont précis qui
sont détaillés et qui sont circonstancié
et aujourd'hui les juridictions que l'on
a les institutions colonna pour le
travail moi je vous dis je suis avocat
en droit des étrangers et je vais
régulièrement devant la cour nationale
du droit d'asile ou devant l'office
français des réfugiés et des apatrides
et ça se passe très bien les officiers
de protection sont très compétents et
donc on ne peut pas m l'épée de damoclès
sur leur tête ça c'est pas possible il
faut il faut raisonner de manière un peu
intelligentes dans le débat ensuite la
deuxième chose c'est que on ne peut pas
à cause des deux fait de certains d'une
personne de manière isolée condamner
toute l'immigration enfin je veux dire
il ya des personnes qui disent faut
fermer totalement les frontières dans un
monde mondialisé comme le nôtre ça va
être très compliqué bon avec le
coronavirus on voit que les pays se
repliait un peu sur eux mêmes etc
mais dans tout état de cause on ne peut
pas remettre en cause des siècles de
droits de l'homme des années des années
de droit d'asile de protection pour deux
personnes qui ont décidé de commettre
des attentats dans tout la donne en
france donc il faut savoir raison garder
il ya un certain nombre de réfugiés qui
sont admis qu'ils deviennent des modèles
pour la france qui deviennent des
modèles républicain
regardez il y avait bien cette personne
dont je me souviens plus du nom mais je
crains c'est monsieur gassama qui a
obtenu après la naturalisation
parce qu'il ya somaliens voilà et ils
étaient issus de l'immigration
donc il y a des milliers et des milliers
des centaines de milliers de
d'entrepreneurs qui sont issus de
l'immigration qui font rayonner la
france à l'international
je veux dire il faut pas partir en
guerre sur des anathèmes
il faut la lutte contre le terrorisme
n'est pas une n'est pas ne devrait pas
être un prétexte à stigmatiser les gens
à stigmatiser les immigrés les musulmans
les c'est pas le but
sinon on est totalement contre-productif
et en fait on donne à die ou aux
terroristes ce qu'ils veulent c'est de
la vraie vie est ce que c'est ce qui se
passe actuellement en france
je crois qu'il ya une petite tendance
quand même à sortir de l'état de droit
oui quand le premier me et le pardon le
ministre de l'intérieur dit mais qu'on a
mené des perquisitions ou on a mené des
enquêtes simplement pour faire passer un
message mais tout s'est tous ces signaux
sont un peu alarmant quand même il ne
faudrait pas que l'on sorte de notre de
notre état de droit on a suffisamment de
dispositions législatives et
réglementaires qui nous permettent
d'agir
je pense que ce qu'il manque ce sont les
fonds et il faut un moment donné qu'on
comprend qu'on se pose et qu'on se dit
qu'est ce qu'on est prêt à mettre en
terme de sous en termes d'argent pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
c'est pas en d'accord en déploie
aujourd'hui 3000 personnes 3000 membres
du corps armés pour pouvoir défendre les
lieux de culte mais à long terme
je vous rappelle que les mosquées sont
quand même un des lieux de culte les
plus menacées en france
à long terme on fait quoi on nous
propose quoi contre ces véhicules parce
qu'à un moment donné l'armé ne pourra
plus assurer la sécurité quand le calme
sera revenu il faudra re déployé l'armée
les réutiliser il ya la crise du
coronavirus on sait que pendant le
premier confinement il ya eu on a
réquisitionné un certain nombre de
manques de l'armée pour faire des
d'hôpitaux de caen donc à un moment
donné on peut pas mobiliser tout et
n'importe quoi il va falloir recruter et
mettre de l'argent ça c'est très
important et je crois que c'est là
dessus que le débat devrait supporter
quelles sont nos ambitions financières
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
qu'est ce qu'on est prêt à mettre sur la
table selon vous à le gouvernement
français n'avait pas assez de moyens
j'entends financière dans cette lettre
je crois que le gouvernement français
met des moyens financiers je ne dis pas
qu'il en mais pas mais je pense qu'il en
mais pas assez je crois que il y a c'est
comme partout vous avez aujourd'hui aux
critiques le service public mais le
service public c'est un manque de moyens
on critique les banlieues mais les
banlieues c'est un manque de moyens donc
au bout d'un moment on est on est un
pays qui est endetté on a un pays qui
connaît un certain de problèmes
économiques on est un pays qui fait face
à une crise qui est quand même inédite
au 21ème siècle
maintenant il va falloir que on se
regarde en face et qu'on se disent
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
est ce que il ya 2 il ya deux il ya deux
éléments de langage savez soit on
stigmatise les gens et on passe notre
temps à diviser les français et ce qui
n'est pas vraiment le cheval de troie
contre le terrorisme
ça va pas être ça ce ne sera pas être la
panacée on le dit franchement ce sera
des populations qui vont de qui vont
être de plus en plus frustrés et qui
vont ceux qui vont de plus en plus
critiqué le gouvernement y aura une
crise démocratique qui va se mettre en
place donc ça ne sert à rien on n'a
aucun intérêt à faire ça
soit il va falloir qu'on se calment
qu'on reprenne un peu nos esprits et
qu'on se dise quelle quelle est la
mesure de nos ambitions qu'est ce que
l'on veut faire
quel est notre priorité aujourd'hui si
c'est de lutter contre le terrorisme
qu'est ce que les services de
renseignement 10 un moment donné il va
falloir les écouter il va falloir
l'écouté leur désespoir s'ils en ont et
il va falloir écouter ce qu'ils
demandent de concret pour pouvoir lutter
encore mieux contre le terrorisme parce
qu'il est impossible aujourd'hui de
mettre une personne des renseignements
derrière chaque fichier s dans notre
pays derrière chaque personne contre
lequel on aura une suspicion d' attaque
terroriste
donc il va falloir regarder tout ça et
et et discuter avec les services de
renseignement ça c'est certain qu'il ya
une faille
au niveau des renseignements français je
moi je n'aime pas les grands thermes
vous savez de failles etc
je ne dis pas qu'il ya une faille je
trouve que les services de renseignement
et je pense et je le maintiens qu'il
font un boulot exceptionnel
maintenant aujourd'hui il va falloir
regarder du côté du renseignement humain
qui a eu tendance à être diminué d'année
en année parce que on considère que
aujourd'hui les algorithmes font le
travail
mais on le voit la vidéo surveillance
qui est qui n'est ni plus ni moins le
calcul d'algorithmes les recherches des
dizaines de profils radicaux à travers
des algorithmes c'est bien ça marche ça
aide mais rien ne pourra remplacer le
renseignement humain et je pense que les
personnes que l'on a perdus dans le
cadre du renseignement humain un moment
donné il va falloir aller recruter de
nouveaux pour pouvoir remettre des gens
sur le terrain et pour pouvoir permettre
de déjouer ce type d'attentât azif arif
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse